it is 4 47 on your monday morning
remember last week i was talking about
the henderson symphony's holiday jukebox
concert turns out it was a big success i
had the honor of narrating the snowman
as the orchestra was playing and i was
narrating the animated movie played
overhead and there was also a talented
soloist check out julia fleischer from
coronado high school
[Music]
he fell in his pocket
and the scarf that father christmas had
given him
was
still there
[Music]
so much fun so much fun with the
henderson symphony i want to thank uh
first of all like the conductor jeff
newman pointed out the volunteer
musicians a lot of them have day jobs or
they're students and they still put in
the time to make the symphony shine also
props to julia fleischer
she said she and her family have been
really into the snowman forever and she
was really pumped about being able to
actually sing in a public performance of
it
did you get to play your flute no the
flute i left that to the professionals
in the orchestra i just did the
narrating but uh one day i want to break
out the flute here
on the show before we get into uh
christmas time okay play a couple of
carols following the producers of the
show that could make that happen
we'll talk to some people how about this
imagine we all just dress up in costume
and go uh do some random christmas carol
singings at people i would have the
doors slams on my face all right
i think we're trying to encourage people
to watch just not sharing a channel
just an idea there's nothing wrong with
trying something new what's your go-to
song hector
also the henderson symphony was
performing at a beautiful auditorium the
crest academy has a new campus that's
right called slow canyon between the am
resort and the raiders practice facility
just an incredibly beautiful auditorium
so thanks everybody that came out and
hope you had a good time
that was awesome great